no one wants telephone call today
because you get a phone call today and
ask to come and see the Prime Minister
that means for getting the chop
today's second day yesterday is when
Cameron tries to do it discreetly so you
don't have to walk up Downing Street you
just go to his office in the comments
and he says thank you very much for your
service but this isn't quite right
Cameron hates these conversations and he
often blurts out something that causes
him trouble down the line but he always
gives the press and say he cradling a
glass of wine all right back to me
yourself already make some promise about
the future it happened to suggest that
all hope is not lost when I think
tomorrow will see that the storms the
result I mean in a sea themes it's meant
to address and the weaknesses of a Tory
Brown so it's a very good reshuffle for
you if you're gonna be a woman or you're
from a working-class or northern
background I think you're gonna see
estimate they basically made Minister
for television which makes some sense
seeing the Minister for TV is in to go
out and defend the government on the
jury
what would your official title I think
you'll get 10 o'clock so job of Minister
without portfolio one of the reasons she
won't get a department I'm something
quite important pass the reshuffle is
Cameron is basically being persuaded
that people have mournful seats like
estimate a shouldn't be given a
department to run or a ministerial job
unless that's gonna help them get
reelected so for example penny more than
in Portsmouth you can send her as a
defense because that's like a clear
constituency interest but apart from
that
um I mean Cameron's quite reluctant to
send people with wafer-thin majorities
into non vote winning departments one
other thing this reshuffle is also going
to reveal fact the Tories are fighting
on several fronts and X direction Preeti
Patel is gonna get a ministerial job one
of the reasons why is that number 10
they're very excited by the fact they
think that she has the ability to attack
both labour and Hugh Kip I mean that's a
reminder the partners towards all
fighting one front at the next election
this is what Priti Patel has had these
capacities for four years now I find it
very odd that she's been left out in
fact the funny thing is that Ted Cameron
talks about this women problem and they
say that you know Theresa Villiers is
for the chop she's not very useful but
you've got really good women junior
women yet
seem to rise to the top of this
government so far why are they calling
it's a lady thing I think one of the
problems is that the Conservative
Party's had to adjust to the fact that
he's really impressive women are also
rebels I'm not prepared to just sit on
the back benches and do nothing they've
plotted their copybook early on like
pretty to tell ya this that makes her
really useful person to provoke she's
not just a woman she's a year a skeptic
right winger so if you're going to sag
and he's from dead word on the
ministerial ranks is from the right
actually put pretty telling you solve
two problems at one right so oddly
they're rebellious Ness is actually
increased their credentials now because
they've got more and more respectability
with the you keep wavering versus
backbenches as well back benchers feel
remain on the back benches during this
reshuffle we'll see people who rebelled
and think that haven't been sucking up
to ministers for the past four years
they haven't been desperate for a job to
the extent that they've sort of
compromised their own instincts
so James M you know Esther McVeigh is to
put it mildly not a household name lest
you remember seeing her in her
telecasting days but is this a reshuffle
which you know will they cite us during
lists but is likely not to be noticed by
the outside world I don't mean is going
to cause huge waves this week
throwing the Tory hope is that during
the general election campaign the people
you see popping up to defend the Tory
Party to take the fight to labor on all
white public school southern males I
mean I think that's one of the things
that they want to address I think one of
the other things they want to us they
want to get him give a sense of dynamism
of a forward momentum
they're very keen to look look to look
like the kind of young fresh government
lesson they don't want to look like
they've run out of ideas come 2015 they
want to look like they've got the team
in place ready to govern for another
five years